[Music]
this
is probably what comes to mind when you
think about north korean propaganda
a hawkish newscast about the country's
battle with the u.s
[Music]
or videos with triumphant music of north
korea's leader kim jong-un inspecting
missiles
but recently the country has been
putting out something different
hello my dear friends i wish this
beautiful april day could cheer you up a
little bit
this is una she doesn't share much about
herself but shows viewers the softer
side of life in pyongyang
from where to get her favorite snacks
to what she does for fun
and where to go running it's my favorite
day of the week you know
it's my day off she speaks to her
viewers in english
though some videos from her channel are
subtitled in chinese
while others in french all in an effort
to target an
international audience they need to do
something to kind of counter this image
of them just being troublemakers
that want to start wars it's not talking
down to the viewer
today is kind of special day for
students to sort of give you this feel
that you're getting something that's
very real
this is really aimed at public opinion
and public opinion
can shift political policy while it's
difficult to independently verify what's
going on inside the country and north
korean officials didn't respond to our
request for comment
outsiders who study the regime's media
say the leadership is trying to rebrand
its international image
we have become one of the very few
covet-free countries worldwide
and revamping its propaganda machine
could sway how outsiders view
the country's handling of the
coronavirus pandemic
very different from anything we've seen
before martin williams is a researcher
with the non-profit organization 38
north and he's been watching how north
korea's broadcasting has evolved over
two decades
one of the country's early forays into
tapping an international audience was in
the late 2000s
with a youtube channel for state media
broadcasts
it's completely impossible for anyone in
north korea to just sort of
start a channel and upload these videos
without there being official approval
for it
in the last couple of years other
accounts have emerged on the internet
and una's videos are not staged like the
broadcast created by north korean state
media
she doesn't sit behind an anchor desk
and is often outside
some of the videos even include blooper
moments
[Applause]
north korea seems to be slowly evolving
in the way that it's trying to tell its
story to the world
we're 20 years into the 21st century but
i think this is the first 21st century
style propaganda that north korea has
tried
for the international audience though it
couldn't be determined who's exactly
behind these channels
echo of truth and new dprk are now
drawing more than 37 000 followers
on chinese social media platform weibo
the new dprk account has more than half
a million followers
analysts say this evolution of north
korean propaganda
is probably inspired by china
in the next 20 days we'll take a grand
road trip which also tightly controls
its media to sway opinion at home and
abroad we'll also learn tonka scroll
painting horseback riding
knife making and dancing they are taking
a page from china's propaganda book
it's a little bit easier for them to to
look at chinese social networks and see
what's popular
and kind of take that as ideas among the
several dozen videos uploaded this year
one theme has come up frequently the
fake news is the last
thing we need in such fierce battle time
with call it 19.
these videos debunk what outsiders have
said about north korea's handling
of the coronavirus outbreak a world food
program report from april
placed north korea on a list of
countries at risk of food shortages
because of the pandemic
a few days later una took viewers to a
supermarket in pyongyang
as you can see all the shops are fully
stocked with products and food to
satisfy people's demand
north korea's economy was already hit by
sanctions and economists say the
pandemic will likely hurt growth this
year
recently a western media reported
about dprk's economy so i'm here today
to
check it out luna asked shoppers if
everyday items are getting too expensive
traditionally north korea hasn't
directly responded to much
press coverage and much international
criticism what we've seen on these
youtube channels is they're trying to
put a little bit of doubt into your mind
but you know maybe everything you see on
north korea isn't quite true
north korean authorities have also
repeatedly claimed the country has had
zero coronavirus infections
though state media reported one apparent
case that was imported by a defector who
had returned in july
four media and north korea watchers have
been skeptical about the claim
there's a lot of suspicion that kovid
has already been
present in north korea for many months
now the entire world is now watching
with amazement and disbelief
in this video from march una explained
the regime's secrets to stopping the
virus
the message from north korea was that
this sort of
well-running society they having this
this efficient government i have
our respective supreme leader has
foreign at the very beginning
an efficient health system that's able
to maintain
hygiene levels which other countries
weren't able to do
it's hard to tell how effectively north
korea's new propaganda will sway
foreigners
but una's youtube channel is already
getting many more views than another one
of the regime's state media accounts
that was set up around the same time
in 2017. i think if the audience
continues growing
i think the next thing you'll see is
north korea putting a bit more money
into some of these videos
and they're going to continue trying to
refine it because the same as any
propaganda it's all about international
public image
the nation the land the freedom
that i can call my life